[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
okay
oh screen what's the screen get in here
you should get screaming here oh my god
get all these people
screen hit me up on discord bro
yeah because uh you don't got too long
there screaming you got too long you
want to get up in here man
he's got a whole two minutes
yeah he could
play time
that's right
we could do a lot of two minutes
i'm sure you can
pause
hey don't judge me
is it just going to refresh like
how does this work
you want the youtube drip yeah i'm on it
right now it says waiting it has to be
yeah it says waiting but like when you
when you play like there's something
else
okay now now it's premiering okay okay
but you using the right youtube link
which one you're using the one from
destiny
let me send you to make sure you go into
the thing
no it's destiny too
okay for the destiny 2 youtube channel
correct yeah yeah all right cool cool
cool you got you good
uh
well forte was supposed to be here but i
don't know what happened to him
zero what's going on
zero in the building it's the loop
you know i mean
all right i'll send him i'll just talk
something
[Music]
it's cool
man this chat's going like crazy
yeah all right oh zero yeah where'd you
know oh i ain't lord that's what's up
the the this game's dead though
you know it's mad dad i don't even know
why people even getting up for this
right
sony exclusive what are you talking
about it's been nice
[Music]
that's it
refreshing
52 seconds they have like a weird
countdown right now
yeah i did i see it now
you just knocked it up for me
just i had to refresh it it was bugging
out
get it so i think it's gonna be about 15
minutes they said yeah it's not a long
one right not a long one today i'm
assuming old school vidoc style probably
pre-canned maybe have one or two
community i mean dabs on
talk about what's going on the key is
gonna be how much they reveal raid
all that good stuff
oh i i i i'll flip if they you know
i'm a little bit
i think i'm a little bit ahead of you
my clock clock is uh
17. my two months yeah
five
four what oh you had us
oh wow wow
yeah yeah
sabathun has our grandest tool taylor
there's paying off narrative threads
that we planted way back in destiny 1.
you know the narrative says they planted
and decided to use now
mistakes in the universe are rising and
it's the greatest challenge that we've
ever faced
what's up what's up
light equals good darkness it's bad
we're really entering
to discern what's in front of us and
what's lurking just underneath the
surface what is your truth now look at
that collector's edition a lot of
bombshells in the witch queen narrative
oh [ __ ] okay
and that's just scratching the surface
of what we're going to get oh oh i see
one of gods
yep
multiple
witch queen and china
is what's going on
oh there he is
light in the darkness let's go
we loving this
we just started we just
started polite
i've been on my destiny grind for the
last three days good to have you back
i never went nowhere i think halo made
us all go somewhere for a little bit oh
yeah you were going for a little bit
we've heard about sabbath for years and
just bits and pieces and then like you
see it slowly building over seasons
until we come to this huge critical
point sabotage is no longer just
not just interfering in little ways
she's now ready hope you got everything
done that you needed to do
one two three
we wanted to make her feel imposing and
very regal and dancing through motion in
some way
offers us a fresh start she's very
manipulative she is very
serious but she also has like she like
katy perry
as well thank you
she promised she'd help us out
but the reality of the situation is
sabbath
is only one
side we've outlived our purpose and it
is to sabotage
it's good to see saladin in the room and
shacks
so how do you beat someone like that it
isn't too late oh you can still no
he's fine
in order to beat the sabbath you need to
understand
her throne world is a manifestation of
sabathun's own personality which is in
which queen going through a
transformation through the light
she has
these areas that she's kind of trying to
shine and push away
for the old high barriers it's much more
atmospheric it's very dense it's very
claustrophobic it's spooky
that's crazy then when you make your way
into the loosen hive area it's a lot
more open and broad
it's definitely brighter it's definitely
more lively
we want people to look at it like an
impression
something that's very pretty from far
away but as you get closer it's not
really what it seems it's it's very
unsettling
you're looking at it got a five dollar
chef from chris jones scribe of the
month watching live for the first time
ever
oh what's up sister this is the seat you
did it's really gonna be exciting
they're gonna get to play that part of
psychic detective
trying to solve the many mysteries of
the throne you're gonna be dreading that
and pit of heresy vibes
which queen campaign i think is probably
the most ambitious campaign we've made
in a very long time solve the mystery
we're building the definitively destiny
campaign so leaning into the journey you
can find in exotic missions or uh the
mechanics you might find in a dungeon
i like hearing that i like hearing most
ambitious campaigns yeah
normally it's just a one and done and
then it's gone they're normally under
sellers you know i felt like i was
really becoming on how big it is
we've also added the legendary get those
chains dj
[Music]
she had them
any kind of player who comes in is
really important if the witch queen is
the psychic detective fantasy and
journey
tokens of the blue throwing on their
flak jacket and defending earth from the
hive guardians and the lucent hive and
sovereignty what is that but i need that
a board on the right
step with the light the first person
of the resident is kyle
you watch them
there's a crap i need us to hit them
she's got this like suppressing
technology that the cabal were using in
season of the chosen and now she's going
to help yo what happened
on the table i don't know when you're
working with kyle you see that hand
cannon
is that the trespasser that's what it
looked
her giant hammer it looks like attached
to a ship and poses an existential
threat to everyone because she basically
has an undead army
in fighting the lucent brood this isn't
our first time in the game fighting
other light bearers but it is the first
time that we'll be facing other light
bearers that have much more relentless
motives get it
elusive here we go when you look at
these hive guardians and when they do
their abilities
you immediately make that connection
like oh
they are using my powers that's beastie
they using our powers you know so
and it has two shields you immediately
are like oh yeah i see that connection
and then it's like
and then you're like it hits you with
those things and then you're dead and
it's just an amazing experience the
guardians themselves kind of feel like
fire team that you're fighting against
you've got everything
imagine if that at these characters
i love
strong possibilities i feel like it has
to be right yeah you know they will be
yeah
if you're not paying attention you are
essentially going to have to play that
over again
they might even be like great bosses too
you actually have to go up and kill
their ghosts
that was like one of my favorite things
oh my god
i guess that kind of answers the
questions about which are which like
acolytes are solar
the knights are
yeah that's your companion
and you're about to crush it there's
gonna be a surprise
am i doing this should i be doing this i
have a ghost yeah exactly ain't no moral
dilemma kill those things is fake
every time i resize this up someone else
joined so far and so we're going to need
better more powerful weapons and tools
to fight against that threat
we didn't support
early on looking at various different
yo he looks so
we wanted to cool
a special weapon archetype that was
effective more at a middle range but
also had these kind of additional roles
associated with it ah man the work from
home the glaze is a projectile weapon
and it is a shield and it's a melee
weapon we wanted to keep that
accountability
first it has an immediacy that you don't
really get when you're using a sword
because the camera is so much further
back because this is also a projectile
weapon with power slower moving
aiming these weapons is about leading
and compensating for the speed of the
projectile and anticipating that oh yeah
first person if you're in a really
difficult encounter and one of your
teammates dies somewhere out in the open
where you normally wouldn't be able to
get to them you can bring that shield up
and actually get the revive and then
fall back
glaives originate with
savathune
trying to steal an extremely powerful
weapon her own use yeah pretty much
everybody can be a tight now yeah pretty
much fine throughout the campaign in
order to reconstruct them we need that
to be the reality anyway
who needs grand eaters
you know how long it's going to take you
to get there all about exactly the thing
that you want to never
and this gives us a great opportunity to
continue to do that
this is a really big season for weapons
in particular we've got eight brand new
exotics
the osteo streaker exotic submachine gun
this is something which guardians have
made but it's modern laughter weapons of
sorrow like thorn and touch of malice
fires swarms of tiny homing projections
and then explode in this poison burst
we have an exotic machine gun where the
whole idea is
be the colossus you can launch a barrage
of up to 20 homing missiles it's a
comical amount of projectiles on the
screen oh you know what i'm gonna be
able to use that one
for each classic grip the exotic perks
tied deeply into the mechanics and out
your loadouts already i think i already
got my load already all additions to
build crafting
cog cleansers loadout the usual suite of
great weapons destination activity
is the name of his game
bro half of my gameplay session is
sitting in my menu making the build
before actually playing the game
six one stasis one non-stasis the titan
stasis exotic cast your barricade
instead of you know this traveler's
light and the rally barricade you create
even though this thing is massive you
still get all the benefits of rally
barricade
warlock void exotic we called them the
devouring rift legs because we wanted
empowering rift to feel like it had a
place in content the way that healing
rift does empowering doesn't heal you
well what if it did
we doing warlocks what are we doing
in season 16 you're going to see warlock
stuff revamp the void subclass assisted
across all three
classes is a development
and will allow players to build craft in
ways that they've never done before
one of the things we wanted to do is
create a core set of verbs
anyone can run suppressors now
yes some
the new titan aspect where you take your
big old sentinel shield slam it into the
ground and create this void barricade
that's gonna apply overshield to you and
your buddies
my favorite aspect is probably a child
with the old gods as this warlock
controlling space and time i'm able to
rip a hole into another dimension and
then pull out this little like sentient
black hole whenever i target an enemy
my little black hole buddy is going to
fly over there and start draining their
life force
they're finally bringing
changing it's all about lightning direct
attacks quickness we're going to take
the fantasies that you know and love
today we're going to embellish them yeah
the rest of the year all of the new
abilities all the new actions you take
reinforce that to the core
pretty excited about it
witch queen is very much the culmination
of the last six to seven years of just
destiny all together and really this is
starting the road to the final showdown
but things like that is really just dark
and we're like just throwing titan
shields
a real fight players have something that
they're really going to be challenged by
yeah warlocks look like they op again
i have the problem
i love that they're showing all the
characters in the cinemas
i think man that's cool cool how you
just bust open the ghost
more destiny coming this year than any
other year before it's one of the most
ambitious releases we've ever put
together and the team is firing on all
cylinders
oh
you said it what you're going to do that
what do you say dj
he said the most destiny
most ambitious only thing they missing
to see now that we got that playstation
money exactly that's what it is
before the playstation well i know
that's what i said no no no playstation
money we can go even further yes
i still want to know what that i still
want to know what the hand cannon was
sitting next to that ghost it was there
foreign
that they all got it on there
i know you would already have it if that
was the case
you got it
what are they just dropping boys what
are the thoughts boys i think that's it
because it's 15 minutes one oh that's
that's a little short one yeah it's a
little shorter
what are our thoughts
addict
i it was cool um
i'm more of like a raid person so i
would have liked like a something on the
raid but definitely
um
i didn't expect it but it would have
been nice if it was there oh you you
going to get a whole rave breakout when
this when the dlc drops because it comes
out with 10 days after
yeah you'll get all that after the dlc
comes out no deal forte what are we
thinking sir look man
i'm just happy to get new content
yes we've been starving that's why a lot
of us take it we took breaks but um no
man just i mean i just can't i never get
over the fact that you know you're
looking at your
own abilities being used against you
finishing ghost off and
it's really going to make you have to be
more close and personal than you
actually think because you got to be in
a certain ratings to do stuff like that
you know it's going to make your builds
like when it comes to light healing and
making sure that you are specked out not
just to do damage but to actually be
able to you know reflect a lot of damage
too and
yeah i think that's something that
people like you know a lot of people are
thinking about it but your video is
frozen into it sorry
the street video supposed to continue i
can't do nothing about it okay you're
good because we and dj looking like
we've we stuck at stasis
pvp right now pick me up break me out no
yeah but yeah i'm excited man it's um
it's the it's the 22nd it's right around
the corner the the cool thing is i ain't
gonna be there on day one right at start
because i know it's gonna be server
issues that night
[Music]
normally i take the day off for a dlc
but you know what your boy did your boy
took the next two days off after that
but i'm gonna allow all of the people to
go in there and be mad and bungee
the first 14 hours of this dlc being out
like the servers ain't working i can't
get in your time's super long but you
know what i can't wait no matter what as
soon as i get home even if the server is
not functioning correctly i'm still
going to try to get in there and uh i'm
going to be doing that and and i know i
know a certain group of guys are going
to be trying to do this rate you know
first
i know we're going to be in on day one
right
oh yeah oh for sure you know kyle i
gotta make sure with you man you know no
no no no no that's a good easy business
to go that's a goal all right
saturdays now so raids and saturdays
that's the greatest thing they did it's
a goal
there it is man but yeah i'm excited man
what what about what about you guys
yeah what's going on dj what you thought
about it man
i mean the void uh all the void stuff
look great um i mean the locations the
glaive look good um i mean it's gonna be
overpowered for sure um
it's gonna be i mean you're gonna have
to level that thing up get it get it up
to par for the raid um i'm ready for it
i'm i'm excited it's about time that's
what we said right so yeah yeah i look
good it all looks the video they're i
mean they always look good they never
let those down it's like what they do
best
no doubt no doubt scream where you been
man what's going on with you how you
feeling about it i've been around sir
you've been sending me party chats when
i but i've been super busy for whatever
reason i usually just hit everybody up
because i never know who's online
anymore i'm not appearing online
appearing
i can't really say much uh forte for
that day that you're uh by the time you
get there i'll have a power level strat
as well as like at least three cheeses
jesus i think i got it at least bring
that to the table i mean it all looks
great to me um i like it
just just to clarify will we do not
cheese day one raids
we always cheese
unless unless we
is like the thing that i'm probably the
most looking forward to i actually
i'm a little i really just didn't like
stasis as much as everybody else likes
these i see that like
and i use it on occasion but it was just
never like
a subclass that i particularly liked
playing but
uh void i really enjoy playing it's like
my favorite subconscious yeah
doing that will be a lot more fun and
maybe it'll even get me
sort of more into playing uh stasis just
because of the mechanics of it i'll kind
of bring that over so i'm looking
forward to it all around you know yeah
it's gonna be awesome too yeah bill
craft i want to see for me i have
actually really excited about floyd 3.0
i'm excited that they're going back to
the essence because the strength of d1 i
felt was you did feel that there was
differences with your specific subclass
like you could configure void you could
configure the super the way you wanted
it you could forget okay i like these
grenades for titans to have suppressors
and all that stuff to be able to
configure you know what i mean is really
cool
the exactly getting into it the two
exotics for the armor which i like for
class
you know they're going to have mad
secrets i'm getting like dreadnought
vibes this thing's going to have a bunch
of series they're going to play into the
whole savithoon mystery
kind of uh my whole thing is story and i
like where they're going when i see
multiple important npcs when i see
shacks in the room with saladin and
saint 14 that excites me like everyone
actually
that that stuff didn't excite me because
i kind of expected those characters to
be in there that cabal excited yeah
but
my thing has always been
destiny sometimes has this problem with
expansion where they just focus on two
characters for the whole expansion you
know what i'm saying the whole season
and i like when you have world events
and everyone's so it feels like yo the
universe is that threat because of what
she's doing what i'm saying so
yeah i feel like
up until now the characters that was in
there
like
the expansions
it made it didn't make sense to
incorporate like a lot of different
characters like because like up until
like now we've not had i mean i guess
you could consider forsaken but
to me even forsaken wasn't like a
world-class event like that kind of was
just with the awoken
and the
and the guardians like they didn't
really incorporate anyone else
uh you know so this makes more sense
because saboteur's here to take over
everything so right now i just my thing
is i still feel there's characters
that
are directly affected you know i'm
saying like for example saladin is very
important to me that he's in there like
there's so many events that happen he's
nowhere to be found we don't know what's
going on that kind of thing but no i
like it i like it i think it's good
storytelling i think they got something
popping with that i just and uh
no no no
he'll be there he'll be there we'll be
fine
optimistic come on hurt i'm hurt i think
it's what your man's over there doing i
think she tricked us
yeah you go get him back you go get him
bags you can throw a body bag with a
curl
well i mean
in the trailer
in the trailer
in the trailer it showed
crows saying you could still redeem
yourself when the said i'll hold you to
that walked away so no that was the old
you you hadn't played that was when the
last this season started and she was so
suspicious and then that's right before
they trapped her into amara trapped her
into the cocoon are you talking about
when he walked away yeah that was
savithoon that was sabaton that was the
cinema right before you started this
season of the loss but if it was sabbath
out loose then how could that be sabbath
too that's because they just they're
just they they weren't showing all
everything in that thing wasn't from the
dlc that was just them showing
stuff leading up to it yeah they showed
the lead up they showed the lid but they
tricked me i personally don't think he's
dead
i think he was being he was being
corrupted
because
if you look at it like she probably used
the exact same method that she used to
control the light to control him
he ain't got no lighting he ain't got no
lights
unless secure gonna show up magically
yeah exactly yeah
it's a wrap but
well i mean i'm holding help hey um can
i just interject one thing um isn't
i don't know how really it will pertain
to all of this but it was just kind of
um something that i saw
um i think uh scaro9 uh actually oh
what are you saying yeah shout out to uh
he noticed that like when you would do
the um is it the astro the astral
alignments yes um
you would there's a bridge being built
slowly over the course of this whole
season that is almost complete now if
you look out on the horizon two
i think yeah i don't know what's
like how did the destin community miss
this this entire year
eve destiny community he called us out
really so it's a bridge in actual
alignment yeah you look back and it's
just like one little gap at the
beginning of the season and now it's
almost complete kind of like
you know how we had the ships coming in
and we saw them on the board
there wasn't something like this
that this season at least not that we
knew of until like
two days ago or yesterday whenever he
posted i don't know if he was the first
person to talk about that but um first
person i saw so shout out to him oh yeah
he's got a video up on it yeah yeah i
gotta check it out
send me
man we back in the mix
then we get that we get our grind going
you know at least we got time for the
raid raise on a saturday i'm hyped man i
want to see what they do and we got a
lot of potential here so that's that's
what i got i mentioned yes
i'm just interested in exactly
what they do because like sometimes they
have a habit
of the raid not incorporating like
i don't want to kill sabathune or
saboteur gets defeated in some way in
the story
and we fight some random thing in the
right
game i want to fight sabbath dude in the
ring
yeah yeah i think they're doing because
this is like kind of following like the
whole um like the whole orange tree and
stuff like that yeah yeah so i think
it's just just like how orange you
fought him in one place in in the uh in
the realm and then all of a sudden you
ended up being him and the boss
so i think they're gonna probably go in
that direction i think they they know
people
don't want to just like who the heck is
axis right
right but who is access yeah that piss
people off
the good thing is they're usually pretty
good at like when they make a good
expansion they usually don't mess any of
it up
i'm confident i'm covered i know i'm
being worried but i'm like i'm
comfortable they're not gonna just hit
us we're what travis says the ooga booga
you fire
cyberthune
uh dj i was interested to see those
three worm gods that we saw right yeah
just popping out yeah just popping up
just like when they're on titan yeah
hanging out it's good
is just the role that
callus is gonna have because it it's
interesting that like they went to her
because she has like light
cancelling technology like like title
yeah
because like the the crazy palace was in
there
yeah where was he at
my story i'll be honest that's a cool
twist
wasn't it in the lore that the leviathan
was the guardian of the worm gods like
it was like the preventer of people
gaining access to him i know that that
word leviathan is used in reference to
like the
yeah like the guardian not the guardian
necessarily but like the um
what would you call it like
the petorian of the the worm gods or
something like that the person that
didn't allow anything to get to them
because yeah like i guess they were
dangerous or something got no idea i
don't know
uh
by that one you've been miling anything
i don't remember we'll go ahead and uh
in this out because uh people gotta go
back to work
so uh definitely uh you know what what
where's everyone at man because we got
like three people in here
no for sure um hype ready to go you
already know the vibes man we back which
queen let's do it and apparently
apparently there is a huge uh a huge
nintendo direct tomorrow but that's
besides the point so
yeah i think in general i'm just getting
back into the game and um especially
with the whole announcement that with
the artifact you'll be able to unlock
all of the mods as you play through the
game right um from beginning to end um
if you can start stacking those bounties
now i i've already filled up two
characters i'm working on my third one
so i can
turn in all those bounties and get as
far through that progression as possible
in the first couple of days of the game
i got a plan for your forte i got a plan
oh i i got to play it too oh
we got it we got to die
all these plants together
yeah yeah videos on deck for those and
stuff but um yeah the iron banner coming
up in a couple of weeks i think next
week or the week i know it's next week
uh so iron banner next week so make sure
you stack those bodies because they
already said that those bounties do
carry over to the next dlc so not only
do you get a crazy amount of xp from
them you also get a chance to get some
of those new weapons before iron banner
comes around because all of that stuff
already codes for that new stuff
no doubt no doubt
let's go